très bien dit que tout pouvait pas
repartir cyril sans reparler de gens me
et oui alors cette semaine il vaut
fayotage ça allait c'est ma dernière on
a vu que c'était un pro de la lèche
faille sommes de moins en moins oui il a
pris un peu cher aujourd'hui on voulait
mettre en avant son côté drôle son
humour son talent il est caustique germi
alors j'ai peut-être un petit concept
d'émission pour vous pour la rentrée
cyril puisque chez vous êtes un très
grand producteur vous connaissez la
grosse rigolade
steve madden a laissé la grosse rigolade
omnium foot battra jamais je le dis de
se permettre à part bien sûr will josh
que de la grosse rigolade qui reviendra
à la rentrée et ben alors moi je vous
propose un autre concept
bon je vous avoue je me suis pas trop
fait chez surnom ça s'appelle la petite
rigolade
eu un peu de chance et c'est grâce à
manu un shérif voilà qu'on a on a gagné
qui a été exceptionnel vous avez écrit
une nouvelle page pas je m'attend j'ai
encore les points regarder et ben ça y
est survenu on la doit à océane qui a
évoqué les différentes conquêtes de naka
way matière vous connaissez la carte à
bien avec un mois non mais sérieusement
fait des mots croisés mots
bien sûr j'en ai fait fait des suites du
cul ouais tu l'as vécu de cela mais j'ai
un chien une chatte
elle s'appelle lucienne c'est vrai
[Rires]
pourquoi on créerait pas un énorme parc
d'attractions destiné à la télévision
c'est à dire que vous viendrez on ferait
un immense n'oubliez pas les paroles par
un immense parcours de koh lanta ont
fait voilà rendus
vous avez une chaîne qui s'appelle
comment j'ai une chienne qui s'appelle h
comme la lettre j'ai demandé aux enfants
de trouver un nom pour le chien ils
m'ont dit c'est l'année des quoi h
mabala ph
j'avais complètement autre chose a fait
pas trop chaud voilà le truc us lundi
qu'à terminer et bah écoute et termine
par une très bonne bande à michel bras
bout